اللي حسب السجلات الحاليه يعد عام 2016
اكثر الاعوام حراره على الاطلاق وهو العام
الذي شهد علامه مناخ النينو في المحيط
الهادي وتسبب هذه الظاهره المعقده في
ارتفاع درجات الحراره في جميع انحاء
العالم
وصنفط المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
عام 2019 كفاني اكثر الاعوام حراره منذ
بدا تسجيل البيانات الدوليه لدرجات
الحراره فمتوسطه درجه الحراره العالميه
السنويه كان اكثر ارتفاعا مقدار واحد فاصل
واحد درجه مئويه عن المتوسط الفتره ما قبل
الثوره الصناعيه وبدا عام 2020 من حيث
2019 ليكون ايضا من اكثر الاعوام حراره مع
الارتفاع القياسي لحراره المحيط واحداث
مناخيه ذات تاثير ضخم شهده ذلك العام
وبحسب المنظمه العالميه التابعه للامم
المتحده فانه متوسط درجات الحراره لفتره
الخمس سنوات 2015 الى 2019 كانت الاعلى
على الاطلاق القادمه
[موسيقى]